like all inquisitive boat you've ever
wondered what had happened to a can of
ravioli air stream of lava well watch
this it clearly says on the tin do not
let the contents boil they will impair
the flavour this explosive experiment
has garnered over 8 million hits since
intrepid volcano explorer Brian Wong
reported how can Brian gets so close to
this molten rock the lava we see in the
clip is called pahoehoe lava and this
moves about 2 or 3 miles an hour it's
about 5 kilometers an hour the fact it
moves so slowly is a good thing because
just under that crust the bright orange
lava reaches temperatures of 1200 degree
centigrade or 2200 degrees Fahrenheit
so what's going on inside the can before
it's hasta LaVista McCann is made out of
aluminum and it's a very good conductor
well soon as the lava reaches it it
starts conducting all the heat from the
lava inside into the ravioli the sauce
is made out of mainly water which starts
to boil producing steam steam normally
takes up 1709 more volume than water but
because it's trapped in the can pressure
rises and Rises until the lid is blown
off and it travels four and a half
meters at 15 feet away from where the
can walk hot lava and cool footage make
for some tasty science